this is the fight of our lives whatever
it takes
he's pretty good at that fries
couldn't stop you be good i we all made
a bond that I think is really
exceptional and rare and we got to do
really great stuff that the fans really
love you know you know that's kind of
coming to an end so it was always a
little bittersweet and it was always on
everybody's mind like you know I'd be in
a scene it's robber and I'd look over it
and we just feel like we did this you
know and that was really moving at times
certainly was you know a lot of
nostalgia to spy sort of melancholy
these people have become family and
we've shared some years of our life
together now
you anticipate it being an emotional
experience but then when they actually
say you know Chris you rapped and then
it's and it's done it's like that
graduation day you know it's coming but
then when it hits you can't prepare for
it was more emotional than I expected
some people move on bananas not us
that's incredibly emotional and we were
bringing two clothes six and a half year
journey for us and ten to 11 year
journey for some of the actors these
characters have come to define major
parts of their careers and their
vigorous with these characters on a
global level this has been in my mind I
think more than anything it's just that
journey from self-centeredness to making
space for others to making space for a
relationship with pepper to having
common tragic things happen like with he
and Captain thank you something we keep
that a little client didn't bring once a
little teeth and then healing because we
had to come together to fight for the
greater good there's something really
profound about it you trust me I do
[Music]
where I put upon my character those very
principles of the family value we're
talking about a superhero of zero
superpowers there's a guy don't wanna
mess with because the values of of him
are unflappable whatever
takes whatever it takes he's just an
everyman there's high school stuff
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie they're
getting ready to release Avengers end
game on blu-ray and Digital so they're
dropping a whole bunch of new deleted
scenes and promos we have Comic Con next
week where they announce their big
Marvel phase four plans and release some
of the teasers for the next couple of
movies so we'll break it all down we're
doing an IMAX take a giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Avengers or
Spider Man moment on the video I'll name
a new winner at the end of this the
Russos separately also dropped a special
weird mystery Comic Con teaser for a
separate panel that they're doing this
is the video that they posted it's very
cryptic their panel is going to be
happening Friday but they incorporated a
lot of footage from their previous
Marvel comic on panels in the teaser you
guys can let me know in the comments
what you think they're going to reveal
based on that teaser because it's really
hard to guess what they're going for for
their panel reveal using all that
previous Marvel Hall H Comic Con panel
stuff from previous years we just
learned about another big deleted scene
Tom Holland when he was doing press for
spider-man far from home talked about
another scene where spider-man is
fighting Thanos and he snaps his fingers
and pulls everyone out of their body
astral style like the ancient one does
with Doctor Strange during the Doctor
Strange movie he said that spider-man
had to save everyone by wrangling all
their body is using his webs to grab
them all so that their physical forms
wouldn't be destroyed before their
astral forms reemerged with their bodies
it was a really cool idea but I can see
why they probably deleted it because
there was so much stuff already going on
with the spider-man character in all
these other battles between Avengers
infinity war and Avengers end game that
at a certain point they just had to say
oK we've already spent a half a billion
dollars making these movies we're just
going to cut it for time they have a
couple alternate versions of Iron Man's
last scene with Thanos there's a couple
different versions of the scene they
filmed at the Avengers tower in 2012
when they're in the lobby with Loki
before Loki gets away with the tesseract
it looks like there was even more
moments referencing vision post Avengers
infinity war in Wakanda there's still a
lot of other deleted scenes from
Avengers infinity Wars that might never
see the light of day there varies
barche with the amount of deleted scenes
they put on these blu-ray releases I
know there's a lot of questions about
what's gonna happen with vision during
Marvel phase four because he's an
Android
Androids can be repaired just like
robots so that was the whole point of
Sheree trying to separate him from the
mine stone she would have the technology
to recreate him if banner doesn't want
to do it himself you see more scenes of
Hawkeye and Japan when he's going full
Roden there's enough material there that
they left on the cutting room floor that
they could have turned it into its own
little Hawkeye movie usually they
expands those parts of the film with
famous Asian actors for their foreign
releases in places like China like the
full-on no joke released an alternate
cut of their Marvel movies pretty much
all their Marvel movies with slightly
different scenes tuned for international
audiences and if there are censorship
considerations in foreign countries like
China is hardcore about the way they
censor their films usually that just
winds up being a longer version of a
scene with an Asian star that's super
popular in China the really good example
is Iron Man 3 with the scientists and
the party at the very beginning when
they released the film in China they
just included a much longer version of
this scene with this Asian actor but
that was it it didn't really affect the
plot of the movie that much as promised
I got Pepper sorted out took some
tinkering but then I thought to myself
why stop there
[Music]
of course there are people who say
progress is dangerous but I'll bet none
of those idiots ever had to live with
the chest full of shrapnel and now
neither will I let me tell you that was
the best sleep I've had in years other
day ah well you think teaching was the
top position in key to legit Oman the
Yakuza person Hawkeye was fighting
during Avengers endgame was Hiroki
sonata he was from West world season 2
you may remember him he's playing a
character called Akiko who actually was
a comic book character even though he's
just a Yakuza in this context but if
there were any questions about who he
was playing he really is playing a
comic-book character
there's a little bit more of the Hawkeye
black widow scenes from Vermeer I've
already done a couple separate videos
about that and even more recently I
posted a video where Jeremy Renner is
talking about a completely different
version of this where Thanos attacks
them on Vermeer so it gives you an idea
for just how many different ways they
tried to make this movie before we saw
the final cut and it's very different
that's in the movie now it's a scene we
brie shot because it is much more
complicated seeing that that's an end
game now there is an attack Thanos has
had some ship or something and a bunch
of weird aliens or run around and made
it too complicated
these are the official deleted scenes
that they've listed for their blu-ray
release there's one called goji berries
one called bombs on board the suckiest
army in the galaxy you used to freakin
live here Tony and Howard in Avengers
take a knee usually deleted scenes are
listed in chronological order where they
would have originally appeared in the
film so goji berries sounds like it's
something from the beginning of the
movie maybe with Iron Man and nebula
scenes on the benitar when they're still
stuck in space by themselves bombs on
board sounds like it's more footage from
their first attempt to go kill the older
version of Thanos when Thor finally goes
for the head suckiest army and the
galaxy it sounds exactly like something
that rocket would say so it's also
probably thrown that original seat where
they go to kill thanos even more rocket
SAS you could just feel it reading the
titles of these deleted scenes you used
to freakin live here sounds like it's
rocket talking to fat Thor when they go
to Asgard during Thor the dark world to
get the aether Tony Howard is obviously
a different scene in the 1970s with Iron
Man
talking to his father and Avengers take
a nice sounds like it's the scene of
everyone meeting up during the middle of
the final boss fight with younger Thanos
at the end of the movie there's a little
bit of footage they've released from
that there's a scene that they film
where everybody who came back from the
dust met up with the other Avengers in
the trenches mid-fight to plan their
next attack and they said it just really
slowed that final battle down and it was
already like a half an hour of the movie
so that's why they wound up cutting the
film but a lot of this stuff will end up
dropping the week after Comic Con of
course I'll do videos for whatever bonus
features they release on the blu-ray
leave all your requests in the comments
below there's still so much stuff going
on that we're learning about from
Avengers endgame and spider-man far from
home there's a new Fantastic Four
spider-man far from home Easter Egg
video Green Goblin and a venom Easter
Egg video that I'm working on that stuff
will post in the next couple of days I'm
trying to give everyone a couple more
days to see the movie if they haven't
seen it yet but there are so many big
Easter eggs so be sure to keep your eyes
peeled when you go to see it next week
at Comic Con is gonna be crazy so as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you'll see all my videos when I
post them no worries but congratulations
to the giveaway winner for my last big
Marvel video Xavier Ramirez please email
me on the about page of my channel so I
can get your details click here for my
breakdown of that spider-man 3 teaser
from the end of spider-man far from home
and click here for that brand new Star
Wars the Mandalorian trailer video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]